the Joe Rogan experience do you ever
conceive of a possibility of coming up
with something that removes carbon from
the atmosphere that's a giant issue with
us right right carbon emissions so
definitely I believe negative emissions
would I think you refer to them will be
required to make the goals to kind of
keep the warming in check its however
it's a much more difficult problem
because if you think of the ocean it's
it's busy a two dimensional problem it's
a plastic on the surface and fortunately
it's not even the whole ocean it's it's
kind of concentrating in these
accumulation zone so the Garbage Patch
although it's twice the size of Texas
it's still one point six million square
kilometers while the ocean is like three
hundred million square kilometers so it
really just may be less than a percent
of the ocean which needs to be cleaned
and it's a again it's a two-dimensional
problem well the atmosphere is it's
three dimensional so it's just this is
one dimensional increase it's just yeah
it's just a huge challenge so I do think
it needs to be
techo and it's definitely exciting
probably to think about I think that's
definitely that's not a good starter
problem to to work huh
no um wasn't there something Jamie that
we had talked about where they'd figured
out a way to make these building sized
essentially vacuum cleaners they were
going to put in the center of certain
cities I believe it was in Asia maybe
perhaps China they'd come up with this
and the I don't know they implemented it
yet but the idea was to have these
enormous things at place that look like
a skyscraper and really it was just a
huge vacuum cleaner for carbon sure I
know they're of a few companies that
working with they've carbon engineering
is one there is also there's also one
out of Switzerland forget the name but
so so definitely good smart people are
working on that problem I'm not sure
where they are in terms of the economics
and it's gonna sit right here when you
mention his carbon engineering is
this one okay so that looks like giant
fans like a huge building filled with
fans we believe humanity can solve
climate change he hikes imagine like we
have filters for air the same way of
filters for water direct air captured
technology carbon engineering more than
ten years in the making that can capture
carbon dioxide directly from the
atmosphere and look at that machine try
to get a close-up on what that thing
looks like it looks like giant [ __ ]
washing machine right like it's washing
the air doesn't it look a giant washing
machine
Wow that mean it seems like it's
feasible it doesn't seem like it's
something that's impossible
yeah I think that's it's the scalability
that that's the main rival engine
well it's also funding like if you drive
over or fly over Manhattan rather and
see the density of the structures and
how many buildings are in there you know
that people can make some pretty insane
[ __ ] right why could they make some
giant insane vacuum cleaner for the air
that's you know as big as a city block
of course a lot of it comes down to
economics or our system it's not very
good at valuing things that our
long-term are directly benefit ourselves
so so definitely people tax it won't
find a way to make it profitable is this
another one rendering of what one would
look like to capture 1 million tons of
co2 per year whoa sounds like it looks
like it'd be noisy
yo yeah probably annoying as [ __ ] look
at those fans
it's so weird though like the whole
array of fans ok that seems like a way
to do it
looks like somebody built a giant
computer and tried to cool everything
and then know how all this carbon what
the [ __ ] they do with that
burn it what do they do what do you make
[ __ ] out of it what do you do make
diamonds imagine that that is her girl's
best friend you make it out of the
carbon that you pull out of the air
that would be a great business model
this would be like a green diamond right
a diamond that's actually made and it's
all pressured by solar power the use
solar power to [ __ ] smash it
carburetor the car had the same carbon
fiber I don't know is it the same [ __ ]
yeah why not right cause be it's carbon
all right so carbon is how they may die
it's coal right which is essentially
carbon right did
make diamonds from carbon or they make
diamonds just from coal what is cool
coals like burnt [ __ ] right there's many
many forms in which carbon exists yeah
so I know they are still structure they
are doing that now where they are making
commercially made diamonds diamonds are
made of carbon
so they form as carbon atoms under a
high temperature and pressure they bond
together to start growing crystals
that's why a diamond is such a hard
material because you have each carbon
atom participating in four of these very
strong covalent bonds that form between
carbon atoms
I've never where'd that read that word
out loud covalent have you ever read
that word out well covalent is that I
said I've never even seen that word so
these bonds that form between carbon
atoms so I know they're doing it now
they're they're making diamonds with
certain machines high pressure yeah if
they did that would be that would be
hilarious that would be a good thing too
because they would put a dent in the
actual diamond market which is this
weird lock down [ __ ] strange market
because diamonds aren't nearly as
valuable as they're set out to be De
Beers takes these diamonds and they
stockpile them and they only release a
certain amount of them they keep the
price very high but it's all engineered
like the profit like diamonds used to be
far more rare than they are now but with
the innovation and mining technology and
their ability to get to diamonds they
couldn't get to before they have a lot
of diamonds okay it's not as valuable as
it appears when you go to buy one okay
so we can make carbon diamonds bro and
actually plastic again cities diamond
chains
yeah we can even make diamonds out of
ocean wow that would be the ultimate
green diamond imagine like if you like a
really ecologically minded rapper you
wear out all your ice could come from
the ocean let everybody know from trash
to treasure yes they dude that's the
[ __ ] that's that's the signature of
the company in quotes from trash to
treasure write these things down boy in
diamonds how about that I like it yeah
dude you could be the first guy to do
this here we go a plastic this is an
ocean
whoa earth is crushing the ocean into
salty diamonds that's a dope looking
diamond to this salt I guess
recreated salty diamond deposits in a
high-pressure high-temperature
experiment suggesting that many of
Earth's diamonds form when the mantle
crushes ancient seabed minerals ah isn't
Science in the earth cool
[Applause]